imagine two universes
in one of these universes life
flourishes on nearly every planet you
can encounter
floating in the atmosphere
swimming in the seas
lounging on the beaches
life
in every body form and size you can
imagine
now
imagine the other universe
where life is nowhere to be found
stars collide
galaxies explode
meteorites crash
asteroids everywhere a time of action
but no life
let me ask you this
which one of these universes is more
interesting to you
which one has more value
so today i want to take you to a journey
to explore and understand origin of life
the future
and where it is headed
and an ethical dilemma that may arise
from understanding this
first things first
earth was formed 4.5 billion years ago
life happened fairly quickly
within the first few hundred million
years so that's very fast
think about that next time you feel like
you're aging too fast
you're not you're fine
and here's how life works
life is a form of chemistry
a form of chemistry that explores
solutions in response to the problems in
its own immediate chemical environments
life is a form of chemistry that retains
a memory of these solutions over
billions of years
and life's first solution was quite the
trick
copy itself
this is astounding we would not be
standing here today if other tricks
didn't follow like how to use water as a
source of electrons or how to use the
nitrogen in the atmosphere
or how to chew on sunlight this is
remarkable
i
am chemistry that explores i am
chemistry that defies degradation and i
am chemistry that remembers
i am a tiny part of an unbroken 4
billion year old heritage
a 4 billion year old linkage
life makes our planet an incredibly
exotic place compared to the rest of the
known universe
this is the only place that it is known
to exist
in fact you can study physics or
chemistry or geology anywhere else in
the universe but this is the only place
where you can study biology
well
i happen to be a biologist
on the only planets where you can be a
biologist in the entire universe
and that makes my job very very special
right
because our planet offers an incredible
opportunity to explore its own origins
and understand how chemistry converted
itself into an agent capable of
responding to its environment and
stimulating itself in response to this
in the past 10 years there has been
remarkable innovations in our
understanding of origin of life
i lead a research laboratory and we are
using statistics and mathematical models
and evolutionary systems
and infer the sequences of ancient dna
that existed billions of years ago
we then synthesize these ancient dna
molecules and engineer them inside
organisms
for the first time we are able to
activate the molecules that existed
billions of years ago to understand and
capture what happened back then
we also stimulate and simulate ancient
environments in the lab to understand
the ingredients
by creating them
from water air and rocks
this means accessing
and obtaining chemistry
that is novel
this means the ability to drive chemical
reactions so that they can create
chemistry that organizes itself
this means having chemistry in hand that
may act lifelike
this is really remarkable
so
we might wonder
what do we do
when we have this knowledge in our hands
this may mean that we would be able to
connect the dots between non-living and
living
and understand how
chemistry is translating and
transforming and transitioning into a
lifelike behavior
this may mean that we would be able to
obtain the recipe of life if you will
and having this recipe would enable us
to connect the dots between these two
states of living and non-living
this may enable us to look at the
particular environment and know how far
along is that particular environment
from its own unique chemical revolution
we might be able to study different
planets and moons and assess them and
assess their chemistry and know how far
along they are from giving birth to life
and we may be able to guide our
telescopes in the vast sky in more
guided ways
in our pursuit of finding life in the
universe
we might also ask ourselves what can we
do with this knowledge
what if we weren't
only assessing
what if we were also interacting
and engaging with these planets
and moons
what if we were able to seed life across
the billions of planets in the galaxy
this would not be seeding them with
earth life
this wouldn't be engineering an earth
organism
and pre-adopt them and precondition them
that in a way that they exist and
survive in this other planetary body
no
this would be this wouldn't be
terraforming altering the environment of
this other planets so that whatever we
ship there makes it
no
this would be about empowering and not
colonizing these environments
this would be about letting them explore
their own unique chemistry to express
their own unique reactions by providing
them the missing ingredients
this wouldn't be about sending them some
life so that we are genetically related
or something that is familiar to us
this would be enabling them to do what
perhaps they were supposed to do or
meant to do all along but
they were lacking and missing
ingredients
and not lacking in the sense that they
themselves were lacking something
important
in the sense that they weren't lacking
right
but what if we were able to send the
spice
the secret sauce
just give it a little nudge
for it to react with whatever is already
present in this planetary body
so that life is sparked
in conjunction and agreements with the
own history and journey and origin of
this own planetary body without our
meddling without our direction without
anything that we do
to direct this in any way
this would be kick-starting a process
that may unfold itself over thousands or
millions of years into the future
but should we do it
this is an extraordinary proposition
and it brings up extraordinary dilemma
about what it means to be alive
does life
as a chemical system capable of
formulating and in some cases answering
questions about its own existence have a
responsibility or should have a
prohibition against sponsoring more life
across the universe
do we do this just because we could
and what is the ethical difference and
is there any ethical difference between
spreading a particular earth life versus
spreading a potential of life across the
galaxy
and where does this difference lie
so i really tried to bring you answers
today
and i don't have any
but i see the paths shaping in front of
me
a universe full with life is interesting
because having solution in hand has
value right
but perhaps the spontaneity and
unpredictability of discovering novel
chemistries and normal life forms is
also interesting and has its own unique
merits
but do we get to set course and let
natural evolution to discover its own
local environment wherever it might be
in the cosmos
an empty universe
in this regard i think can be viewed as
an wide-open palette for solutions
waiting to be discovered
but should we do it just because we can
it is very important to keep in mind
that earth is our only home
and it's a good planet and you know the
saying good planets are hard to find
i know that i've been looking for one
i'll i'll let you know when i find a
good one
exploring the origins may allow us to
truly understand life around us and
perhaps an exercise like this may
encourage us to truly appreciate and
understand how life emerged here at
first place i really think that in order
for us to understand the biology and
life around us we really need to
understand how life happened to this
planet at first place
i really really believe in this i will
dedicate my life to do this and before i
leave to do that back to my lab that i
missed very much
let me ask you again
a universe that is empty
and one with a lot of life which one of
this is more interesting to you
thank you
thank you very much